James oh
my God
I cannot see that Kris Jenner just
caught James Corden taking a shower in
Kylie Jenner's office bathroom well kind
of tune in because you never know what's
going to happen during Tuesday's episode
of The Late Late Show James gave the
Kardashian family's personal assistance
the day off and did his best to fill in
James kicked things off with a famous
momager with cameras rolling for the
family's Hulu series which returns for
season 3 in May I wish I could tell you
this is going to be a mild relaxing
Serene season
it's not the episodes are more a little
bit documentary style what's really
happening behind the scenes the only
place they don't go with me is the
shower and it's funny Chris should
mention the shower because a little
later James made himself at home at the
Kylie Cosmetics office getting naked and
hopping in the makeup mogul's personal
shower
[Applause]
of course Kylie gave fans a closer look
at that epic bathroom on her YouTube
channel in 2019 and honestly we don't
blame James for wanting to test it out
this is my bathroom so I was really
excited about this shower but that
shower mishap wasn't James's only flub
oh boy when Chris requested a
post-workout smoothie he went rogue
cucumbers
spinach
Avo
ID a bit of wine
some members of this family I know how
to chop a cucumber of course that was a
playful dig at Kendall Jenner who went
viral for her haphazard knife skills on
an episode of the Kardashians last year
I definitely not a good cutter so don't
zoom in on me
I'm not professional whatsoever but back
to James it's a little something else
not only did he add wine to Chris's
smoothie we'll get some chocolate
raisins apple cider vinegar
Rice Krispies
and yes according to Chris it was just
as gross as you'd imagine
okay so he didn't slay that assignment
and he didn't Ace the test with Kim
Kardashian either what's going on James
chauffeur the skims founder around town
in her Rolls-Royce
[Music]
but it's a it was describe
and yeah they hit a bump in the road
literally and figuratively are you being
serious no I'm serious no you're not the
whole bottom no you're not stop stop oh
yes
yeah Kim showed off her acting chops and
had James fooled I don't know what's
gonna top that and Kim's about to put
those skills to good use earlier this
week the mama four announced she's set
to star in the new season of American
Horror Story alongside Emma Roberts
which I'm so excited about and while Kim
is busy at work a source tells E.T she's
open to dating again too and putting
herself out there she is feeling good
and confident and is in a great place
foreign
[Music]